everybody it's gary vaynerchuck he
shaved newly cleanly shaved
unfortunately because my jets destroyed
my life and lost to the dirty dirty
Denver Broncos yesterday and I hope we
see them again I'd like to pound them in
the face I just think we we got ahead of
ourselves
don't ever get ahead of yourselves don't
read your own press clippings because
it's very dangerous that's probably what
I should have done the video on today
but I'm going a different direction um
one thing I've realized is that I have a
lot of ideas and a lot of things that I
see out there in the marketplace but
unfortunately not gonna be able to
execute on all of them and so I'm
garyvaynerchuk.com right now I want to
start talking about certain things
certain you know AJ and I thought about
having the show called like the million
dollar business idea where like every
week would come out with like a new
concept for a business model kind of
like it did not too long ago but the
baseball card show that I did that a lot
of you like the hockey card shows out
there now a lot of people followed up on
well I'm gonna give you a big one and
you have to be a baller and you're gonna
need a couple bucks to pull this one off
but the big play the open gap in the
internet business world today like the
six trillion miles hole that has the
billion dollar out you know and it's not
revolutionary this is not like oh my god
Gary's some alien from a different
planet with skills we've never heard or
seen before huh this is obvious and
somebody needs to execute this my
friends the big business idea that's out
there right now is the QVC Home Shopping
Network internet play this is a big
thing pay attention to what I'm saying
to you online video low production cost
live streaming Ustream style slap it on
a site and then affiliate link
underneath yourself for the rest of your
life you will make straight cash if you
have the skillset and you can get people
on the show that will also help you with
that same thing that can be seen us
nothing different get people on let them
affiliate with you live stream it build
up that credibility you have a billion
dollar player I'm telling you this is a
replica to what Amazon did to the book
industry in my opinion it is wide open
I mean wide open for some three four
person
team a little charisma in a host or two
and street hustle cold-calling like I
did in that last video and just hitting
it out of the park by putting product
after product that's a product on video
live on the Internet
building up that audience and then just
selling it through affiliate link it's
easier to click and shopping cart than
it is actually to even call QVC and
place an order bot it's even a lower
cost of entry plus in the beginning you
don't even have to make the business
deals yourself because things like
Commission Junction and all these things
out there have nothing but affiliate
links left and right within a week or
two a month after you get a little hype
your peel box will be full of crap for
you to sell on this show so I'm telling
you put it together you got time in your
hands
live stream when you make a Billy make
sure you throw me a couple hundred milli
have a wonderful day happy holidays and
I'll see you next time